Yesterday,
Yel Dorado took the jump again.
He had not followed up since the
bleau final which was at the end of August
and he came back a few weeks ago
2 months with
and after jumping 1
small line last week with me,
it was time for him to find Benoît
to link 1 little bit.
They started by making 1 relaxation
quite simple on verticals,
then Auxerre
before starting on 1 typical competition course.
And let's go skip the N° 1!
The course was not very big,
it was the opportunity
ideal to put it back on the bars.
the young horse season does not start until March,
he will resume the jump
gradually over the course of winter.
Yel Dorado was in good shape and I think he has very
very well jumped.
In any case,
Benoît, his date,
was very happy and obviously so was I.
It did not land
no questions during the whole course
and frankly he has not lost anything for 3 months.
I am very proud of him and I can't wait to see him
evolve on winter work
before resuming the season.
In any case,
his break really did him good
and I hope that,
deux-mille-vingt-quatre,
it will shine as much as indeux-mille-vingt-trois